let's start by talking about this spring
offensive we keep referring to and what
does it mean where are the key areas of
concerned because we know that fighting
is ongoing so what happens comes the
spring
although the fighting is continue at the
moment in the winter
um I've got colleagues who are out to
help delivering AIDS the roads are
possible but a lot of the fields are
completely impossible that means
maneuver Warfare is really really
difficult but come springtime when the
land hardens up again spring offensive
can start so both sides are expected to
launch major offensives now let's be
clear I can't get inside Putin's head or
zelenski's head but from a military
perspective And discussing with analysts
we can have a quick stab of what's going
on from a Russian perspective Putin's
focused on the special military
operation and that seems to be around
the donbass and the Crimea it's almost
certainly what he'll be looking to do is
protect his lines of communication up to
the north the p66 it'll almost certainly
as well be looking to reinforce
positions around zapparicha to stop the
ukrainians breaking through there but
the main focus will almost certainly
about back move to real a major push
there we're already seeing some build up
of military forces in the area which is
a clear indicator secondly It's
relatively close to the Russian border
so resupply is easier and thirdly we're
not seeing much of Russian Air Force so
far and of course once spring climbs and
the weather improves they haven't got
far to go to get there so they'll be
less vulnerable from a Ukrainian
perspective we'll expect to see them try
to restrict Russian progress here
unlikely to be able to stop it
completely but they'll try to eke out a
really heavy price from Russia for doing
that almost certainly they'll be trying
to interdict the p66 the lines of
communication down but the key thing
we're expecting ukrainians is some form
of push down here to break the line from
Crimea up to donbass that that land
bridge there but all of these Ambitions
for Ukraine are heavily predicated on
the arrival of tanks from the West yeah
let's talk about where we are Poland on
tanks Poland officially submitted a
request to Germany for them to send the
tanks they have to Ukraine we're hearing
reports that Germany could approve that
by the end of this week but it's not
just Poland the UK have committed
another Eastern uh European nations are
hoping to where are we in the the supply
chain if you like part of this is the
sensitivities around Germany about
committing to tanks and I think although
nothing's been decided yet the German
Minister Anna annelina bearbrook
announced just earlier on today uh here
she is at the press conference that that
actually Germany would not stand in the
way of other countries providing those
tanks now until now Germany needs to
provide the export licenses and the
whole Focus was on Germany well of
course Germany for all sorts of
historical reasons and written into
their constitution it's really
uncomfortable for them to be at the
Forefront of this decision so not
standing the way is a is political
language for we're likely to approve it
as you say Poland has applied for it and
therefore really fully expecting and
that will allow Germany to focus on
potentially spare support because all
these tanks will need spare support but
also there'll be training getting the
tanks in there first thing even if they
arrive tomorrow they wouldn't be able to
use them until that training has been
done and I think always for your Fury
about tanks shows the critical
importance of Western technology in this
war and one of the reasons why the
Kremlin is increasingly been upping the
ante up and threatening the West if
these appear and can we just talk
briefly before we go about attention in
the Russian military ranks we are
hearing about a bit of a falling out
between the Russian top brass and the
wagler group which is the mercenary
group that is operating with Russia in
this war yeah I mean we haven't got long
so um richly focusing on progozny at the
Wagner group he used to have about fifty
thousand uh convicts he's Guinea
pregosity on the left here Putin on the
right 50 000 convicts apparently down to
about ten thousand now huge casualty
rates some of them being captured some
of them are just run away there was a
time when Putin it was useful to use the
Varna group his military forces had
stalled the the bargain groups at the
lead made some progress but at huge cost
but also pregosity started to get ideas
above his station now they've got Garza
morph in the new Russian general he's
now much more focused on delivery
military effect it appears that
yevgeny's days are numbered